quiero que observes lo que tenemos aquí
de color anaranjado si observas esta es
una serie es decir la suma desde uno
está infinito de 1 / n elevado a la pep
y lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar acerca de las condiciones es
decir para que peso esta p serie va a
converger y para que sea una p serie por
definición
pep tiene que ser mayor que 0 así que he
puesto por acá estas gráficas para
pensar un poco en cómo vamos a saber
cuando esta pc de converja entonces en
esta primera gráfica observan tenemos la
curva
esta es la curva de igual a 1 / x alape
y estamos diciendo en términos generales
ya que es mayor que 0 que sabemos que va
a ser una función decreciente como en
esta otra segunda gráfica donde una vez
más aquí tenemos bien igual a 1 entre x
elevado a la pep y ahora lo que hemos
sombreado de color blanco debajo de la
curva y sobre el eje x positivo
integral impropia desde uno hasta
infinito de 1 / x a la p de x así que
esta área fue lo que sombre amos antes
de empezar el vídeo en ambas gráficas
bien ahora lo que tenemos aquí
visualmente es que existe una
convergencia y divergencia muy estrecha
entre esta p seria y esta integral que
tenemos aquí ya que cuando vemos esta
gráfica de la izquierda podemos ver que
esta serie puede ser vista como una
aproximación de riman por arriba de esa
área a qué me refiero con eso bien
piensen en el área de este primer
rectángulo el ancho es de 1 y la altura
es de 1 entre 1 / pm ya que este es el
primer término de esta p seria entonces
este rectángulo solo tendría un área de
ojo las escalas de x de james no son las
mismas ahora observa el segundo
rectángulo el área de este segundo
rectángulo sería 1 entre 2 elevado a la
p el área del siguiente es de 1 entre 3
elevado la penn y así sigue entonces la
suma de estas áreas de esos rectángulos
es el valor de esta pecera y lo que
puedes ver es que cada uno de estos
rectángulos está abarcando más que el
área bajo la curva así que sabemos que
el área bajo la curva será mayor que 0 y
que esta serie va a ser mayor que la
integral desde 1 este infinito de 1 /
exhala pep de x es decir va a ser mayor
que el área bajo la curva pero si
sumamos 1 al área bajo la curva en esta
ocasión no solamente estamos hablando
del área en blanco también estamos
hablando de esta área de rojo que acabo
de agregar entonces ahora nuestra pcd va
a ser menor que uno más esta integral ya
que el primer término de nuestra serie
es igual a 1 y luego todos los demás
términos pueden verse como una
aproximación de riman por debajo de la
curva y pueden ver que encajan debajo de
la curva y además dejan un poco de
espacio así que eso va a ser menor que
la expresión 1 más la integral de 1
infinito de 1 / x la p
ahora pensemos en lo que pasa si sabemos
que es integral de aquí divergen es
decir no convence a un valor infinito
bien entonces la p se va a ser mayor que
eso hace que se le integra el divergen
entonces la p seria
en definitiva divergen del mismo modo
así esto de aquí convergen es decir esta
integral va a tomar un valor finito
bueno pues uno más es integral aún va a
converger
así que nuestra psr también debe de
converger debe ir a un valor finito y
todo lo que estoy hablando aquí es en
realidad la prueba de la integral cuando
pensamos en pruebas de convergencia y
divergencia a veces utilizamos este
método pero sólo me estoy asegurando de
que tenemos una buena comprensión
conceptual de lo que está pasando y no
una aplicación ciega de la prueba de la
integral y ahora bien también podrían ir
de otra manera si la p sería conveniente
entonces seguro que esta integral va a
converger y si la p serie divergen
entonces seguro la expresión uno más
esta integral que tengo aquí va a
divergen y por lo tanto la integral
muy bien con esto podemos decir que la p
serie convergen sí solo sin esta
integral que tengo aquí converge así que
encontrar bajo qué condiciones o para
qué valores de pecom bergel ap serie se
reducen a encontrar bajo qué condiciones
esta integral convergen así que déjame
bajar la pantalla y vamos a pensar en
que tiene que ser verdad para que esta
integral converjan entonces déjame
escribirla tenemos la integral impropia
desde 1 hasta infinito de 1 / x elevado
a la p de x y bueno voy a decir que esta
integral es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme el límite cuando m tiende a
infinito de la integral de uno hasta m y
en lugar de poner uno entre x alape voy
a poner x elevado la menos p de x
elevado a la menos p de x
y por ahora permite enfocarse solamente
en nuestra integral el integral de 1m x
a la menos px y sólo recordemos que al
final vamos a sacar el límite cuando m
tiende a infinito
ahora vamos a fijarnos qué valores puede
tomar esta integral ahora ya sabemos que
es mayor que 0 así que en esta ocasión
tenemos dos casos el primer caso es
cuando te vale 1 porque si te vale 1
entonces esto va a ser simplemente la
integral de 1 hasta emmen de uno entre x
de x y así tendríamos que esta es la
integral de uno hasta m de xcel a menos
uno de x lo cual es exactamente igual ya
sabemos el logaritmo natural de x
evaluado en uno y en emmen entonces esto
va a ser el logaritmo natural de m - el
logaritmo natural de 1 si hacemos la
evaluación y después podemos recordar
que el elevado de acero es igual a 1
entonces el logaritmo natural de 1 ya lo
sabemos es 0 así que en este caso
especial esto se va y simplemente me
queda que cuando p es igual a 1 la
integral de
hasta m que nosotros buscábamos
simplemente se reducen a logaritmo
natural de m
ahora pensemos en el segundo caso donde
p no es igual a 1 bien en esta ocasión
lo que podemos usar es la regla de las
potencias que aprendimos en la
diferenciación básica así que
incrementamos el exponente 1
eso me quedaría x elevado a la menos p
más 1 que de hecho lo podemos escribir
más fácilmente como x elevado a la 1 pm
y luego lo dividiremos entre 1 - p y
ahora vamos a evaluar este resultado
desde 1 a m y entonces esto va a ser
igual lo podemos escribir después de
evaluarlo común m elevado a la 1 - p
entre 1 - p ya eso hay que quitarle la
evaluación en 1 que me quedarían 1
elevado a la 1pm entre 1 - pm y ya que
tengo
estas dos respuestas ahora vamos a sacar
los límites que dijimos que no íbamos a
olvidar así
recuerden no solamente necesitábamos la
integral de 1 m de exhala - pep de x no
solamente necesitamos acá delante
derivada aula integral definida sino que
queremos sacar además el límite cuando m
tiende a infinito entonces cuál es el
límite del logaritmo natural de m cuando
m tiende a infinito bien si m va hacia
el infinito es decir no está acotado el
logaritmo natural seguirá yendo hacia el
infinito así que cuando p es igual a 1
el límite cuando m tiende a infinito de
esta integral no converge en esta
integral no está acotada así que sí p es
igual a 1
entonces divergen
bien ya sabemos esto ahora pensemos en
el otro caso pensemos en el límite
cuando m tiende a infinito de esta
expresión que tengo aquí y se observa
toda esta expresión que tengo aquí en la
única parte que está afectada por el
límite es la parte que contiene a m así
que podemos escribir esto como bueno
primero podemos sacar 1 / 1 - p y decir
que queremos encontrar 1 entre 1 - p que
multiplica al límite cuando m tiende a
infinito de m elevado a la 1 pm y luego
por separado podemos restar todo lo
demás tengo 1 elevado a la 1 - pm se
observa en general para cualquier
exponente esto va a ser uno dividido
entre 1 - p es correcto
porque no observa no importa qué
exponente tengas en 1 - p 1 elevado a
cualquier potencia va a ser 1 y entonces
lo interesante es si convergen o no
convergen el límite cuando m tiende a
infinito de m elevado a la 1 - p
entonces todo va a depender si el
exponente es positivo o negativo observa
si 1 - pep es mayor que 0 si voy a ser
infinito y estoy elevando a m a un
exponente positivo entonces esto va a
divergir sí 1 - p es mayor que cero
podemos marte de ambos lados y esto es
lo mismo que uno mayor que pep o p menor
que 1 sip es menor que 1 la integral
vive bien hasta ahorita sabemos que para
hacer un menor que p menor que 1 y para
p igual a 1 la integral va a divergir
ahora viene falta pensar un caso qué
pasa si el exponente de m elevado a la
1pm es negativo es decir si uno
p es menor que cero piénsalo un poco
tendríamos algo de la forma 1 entre m
elevado a un exponente positivo esa es
una forma de pensarlo así que cuando m
se aproxima infinito m elevado la 1 - p
se va a aproximar a 0 y justo es aquí en
este caso donde converge hemos donde
llegamos a un valor finito y entonces si
sumamos p de ambos lados me va a quedar
que si uno es menor que pero si p es
mayor que uno entonces esta integral con
b entonces ahí lo tienen
hemos establecido que la integral desde
uno este infinito de uno entre x la p de
x va a converger sólo en el caso donde p
es mayor que 1
si es mayor que 1 la integral convergen
y si 0 es menor que p menor o igual que
1 en este caso la integral diverge y si
regresamos con todo esto podemos decir
que nuestra serie convergen solo en el
caso donde per es mayor que 1 si p es
mayor que 1 entonces convergen y si 0 es
menor que p que es menor o igual que uno
en este caso diverge y ahí lo tienen